What I keep seeing people saying that
I'm not supposed to pray for him because
he said this about Israel, he said this
about Palestine.
It's like go back to your country. Keep
your
>> Subhan Allah. When I've seen this clip
of our brother, dear brother Sneo, I
couldn't believe what I was listening
to.
And by the way, the clip is longer. He
was swearing, so I didn't want to play
all of it. So our brothers do is very
angry at some people who said we don't
want to pray for Charlie Kirk.
So me myself, I didn't know a lot about
Charlie Kirk. When I made my last video,
some people sent me clips and videos
where Charlie Kirk spreading lies and
misinformation intentionally against
Islam.
And he compared our beloved prophet to
one of the worst criminal of our time.
And he was justifying
the murder and the evil acts of the
Israeli snipers against our brothers and
sisters.
So why sneak we having a problem for
people to express their freedom of
speech by telling them go back to your
country?
So that's that clearly go goes and guess
what is what you lot or even Charlie
Kirk was calling to which is an absolute
freedom of speech.
So they're not they're not inciting no
violence. They're just saying we don't
want to pray for him and we have no
feelings for him because he himself
Charlie Kirk he had no feelings. He did
not care about the feelings of the
children of people of Gaza and the woman
people of Gaza. Why? While some parents
in Gaza were losing their children,
likewise some children in Raza losing
their parents, Charlie Kirk had no
problem to justify the murder and the
genocide that has been carried out and
still against our brothers and sisters
in Gaza. He had no problem to say it
openly while they were getting killed.
So why there is double standard? Even
there's Jewish people now in so-called
Israel are calling out and exposing
Natao to be a terrorist and there is
genocide. Even some Jewish people in
Israel and out Israel and you claim to
Muslim instead of utilizing your
platform to show the hypocrisy and a
double standard of his followers. If his
followers want people to show sympathy
for Charlie Kirk, why Charlie Kirk when
he was not showing any sympathy for the
people of Gaza and the children of Gaza
and the Raza? Why they had no problem
with it? Why the hypocrisy? Like I said
again, I have to repeat it. We're not
justifying what took place to him. All
right? Like before I mentioned, you
cannot take the law into your own hand.
And this this is from the Islamic
teaching. You go back to the authority.
All right. So to pray for whom? You pray
for someone who is known to to to be
Islamophob who is known to unite and
promote Islam haters who were known to
spread misinformation and the lies
against Islam and be by way of that
people will start carrying out violence
against the Muslims in America and
Europe.
So he's in
my advice to you pray for yourself and
if you want to pray pray to Allah guide
his family and Allah guide his followers
to the true Islam.